you've dived in volcanic Lakes at high
altitudes to study the creatures within
can you tell me the technical the fun
the human story of that effort the the
image that is associated with the
scientist is the person with the white
coat in the lab
in fact
um a number of us at Institute are
athletes doing extremes what would be
considered extreme stuff uh uh and not I
mean it's fun it's a little dangerous
too but it's to get data and more
knowledge so there are so many stories I
don't even know it was the first time
you did a dangerous thing with a volcano
oh so the the first one Associated to uh
the search for Life understanding was in
2002 uh where I started climbing those
High volcanoes in the Andes that are 20
000 Footers The View out there is just
beautiful you get
I is so hilarious at spending almost no
time on some epic things I love this
okay with this volcano okay how tall is
volcanoes what are you doing with a
volcano what's required to prepare for
that what does the mission look like
that look like I mean how do you I mean
that is true that this is science
embodied it's like Athletics and it's
science and you're studying the extreme
conditions of life on Earth extreme
beauty of life on Earth in those
conditions so what what was what was
them what are we talking about with this
volcano what how big is it remember when
we were talking about how do I
understand how I search for Life on Mars
this is how it started for me and then I
looked at the environment in my head
started you know going through the
environment on Earth that would be good
analysis and then you only have a few
and the Andes in that case are some of
the best in the world just because of
the aridity of the place and the higher
you go
the least atmosphere you have the more
UV radiation you have and the Andes are
volcanic hydrothermal plus you have the
climate change that's coming you have
evaporation
it's a picture of Mars 3.5 billion years
ago and so now you are actually entering
a time machine yeah basically
so
um remember I'm a diver
and the first time I got in 2002 to the
places uh we wanted to explore
all of a sudden I was standing at 14 000
foot looking at twenty thousand feet and
saying okay
well I need to get up there
are you scared no no because we are
prepared and the only thing I didn't
know is if I was going to be able to
make it to the top because now you're
dealing with high altitude you can deal
with high altitude sickness you can deal
with a number of things and for God's
sake these are volcanoes and they are
dormant they are not extinct that can
buy to buy toast a couple of times what
was your preparation for that kind of I
mean this is there is a lot of uh you
know hiking and trekking and I altitude
around here but not so high because we
don't have anything closer to those
elevations around here in the U.S but in
in volcanic environment climbing
volcanoes here we have plenty of those
diving as well I am a free diver so this
is where it's going to be hilarious
because I started with a completely
rational fear of pressurized vessels
that
comes from an incident in my childhood
and so I became a free diver to avoid
having to carry oxygen tanks on my back
free diving is diving without without
anything just your lungs right that was
that started from childhood yeah no it
was to the point where when I
I saw a pressure vessel like a metal
tanks or anything I would be you know
going around and put a lot of distance
between me and that tank so I was not
going to carry any oxygen tank
um and in the first time I actually died
at the summit of that like was free
diving people look at me like I'm nuts
well maybe I am a little bit people that
work with you as well I mean that that
kind of seems kind of nuts no uh we do
with the risk actually it's a lot of
less of a risk than uh getting with
conventional air and I can explain that
but uh ultimately what decided me to
certify Scuba
and go over my fear was that as a
scientist I needed more time at the
bottom of the lake to sample you know
rationally take my time to think and
I can stay quite long enough
as a freediver and the water
but the last thing you want to do at
twenty thousand feet is to come up at
the surface with empty lungs because
there is not much you can breathe out
there to replenish your oxygen so
definitely your time in the water is cut
short just for safety and I realized
that it was not a good trade-off for me
at some point so I I certified scuba and
after three years of exploring that like
free diving we finally came up with a
full scuba diving Expedition but we were
diving with rebreathers which means that
we dived with pure oxygen
so Rivers give you a bag
with stuff that looks like cat leaders
in it which is basically to absorb the
CO2 uh that you are expelling when
you're breathing and they're recycling
oxygen this way so basically you are
rebreathing your own
respiration wow yeah how long can you do
that so what's what's the what's
interesting about the technology so it's
very interesting because then that
completely avoids the potential issues
you may have with the binds when you are
diving the risk of bubbles uh trapped in
your lungs because of different
pressures and different gases oh so
there's there's a complexity to the flow
of oxygen
underwater when you are breathing
regular air when you are scuba diving
here you know that you have to do some
uh different when you're coming back
when you are diving deep and you have
conventional air then you need to stop
so that you can equalize the gases in
your lungs if you come back too fast
then you can have air bubbles stuck and
then you can raise the binds which you
can wish to be paralyzed you can raise a
number of nasty issues and we want it
absolutely to avoid that so diving with
pure oxygen avoids this completely
and it has a another uh benefit and I
altitude is that well
the greater risk when you are at high
altitude is altitude sickness what is
altitude sickness is just you not having
enough oxygen in your blood so these you
know this was a good benefit it was a
good trade-off we were lucky enough to
be also trained by the military so we
came up with not the civilian rebreather
which is the big thing on on the back
that you carry on your back we actually
were given Navy Seals Commando rib
Rivers you worked with Navy Seals for
this the director of military operations
yes we were trained we were trained like
astronauts for three months I spend more
time I had a joke that if somebody
wanted to reach me they better put a
phone line at the bottom of the swimming
pool because this is where I was so we
trained and we trained and our manual
about the safety was about that thick
so it was a real operation
that was three years into into it
because when you are free diving in the
Years prior there is no risk you don't
have any other gas in your lung that
what you're breathing the only Rises
come short of air and then you're in
trouble which happened to me uh one time
seriously so probably about that time I
got to ask you about free diving before
we return to the rebreathers well all
these legs I had altitude they are
called they are at the minimum
temperature that you can have on bodies
of water uh clear bodies of water which
is for degree C it's very very cold and
so you can take a nice path
yeah so you cannot
um
just dive with a wetsuit
so the idea was to take a dry suit and I
learned how to free dive with a dry suit
which is really the worst thing you can
do what's a wetsuit what's addressing so
a dry suit a wetsuit is usually what you
use in the ocean when it's not too cold
you can use also dry suit but the
wetsuit basically is going to keep you
warm because water is getting into the
suit and at the contact of your skin is
getting to body temperature and so for a
while you can you know dive like that
and need in the ocean here that's fine
that that that's fine the dry suit is
the opposite it's completely closed
which means that you don't have any
contact with the water outside and you
keep your warmth through your body
temperature and even clothing that you
can put into it so this dry suit they
are used by either go really deep in
very cold water and need to stay a long
time underwater so what's the bad part
the bad part is that
when you have those uh dry suit
you have a lot of air that can be
trapped in it usually we do what we call
burping the suit it's not very pleasant
expression but you get in the water and
as soon as you get in the water you can
see the air pockets all over the place
right so you burp the suit you open the
valve and the air comes out once you
have done that then you look with your
lead belt and and you know when you're
ready to go down and so what happened
that day
is that I actually did verb the suit but
didn't realize I worked it completely
and so I went down
and immediately I felt an air pocket
going to my legs so basically air was
trapped in the suit and went on my legs
as I was diving like that and so I
didn't pay too much attention to that
because you're diving down yeah I was
driving down and so didn't pay too much
attention about that as I was you know
busy it's just an awkward position but
then I wanted to turn and go up
well no can do I was just like a buoy
and I was like that so uh the first time
I say okay I tried a second time and the
third time and by the fourth time I kind
of realized I was in trouble and the
fifth time I say okay now you better
give it your best try otherwise it's
gonna be big trouble
um and you're this is free diving I was
free diving and then you can and I
cannot what are you feeling I mean is
there a panic or no there is no panic
because you can't you cannot afford to
be panicking in fact you are always
thinking because there is training this
is the best part about training your
training allows you that space to keep
you cool
and and compose which you need to be in
that kind of situation and so finally
after the fifth time I was able to
rectify the position and get myself up
but when I got up my lungs were empty I
had been in the water for quite some
time and I of I knew what was going to
happen so I decided to just be the plank
you know not move and don't do anything
just open my mouth and try to suck
oxygen but obviously oxygen at six
thousand meters 20 000 feet there is not
that much it's about a little it's a 48
of what you breathe at sea level
so although it was noon at that time
the skies that pretty dark and starry
foreign
can you possibly train for that like
because can you also pass out oh you
could I mean the fact that I was already
seeing dark was a real sign that my
brain was starved of oxygen and I had
one of my uh friends or colleagues on
the on the shore just telling me because
I'd been under for a little while and
say is everything okay and I I remember
trying to say something and and I was
just like
oh that's I think the best lie I ever
ever I get the thumbs up you were lying
to the friend and maybe to yourself uh
no uh because I knew I was going to be
okay but it took me to be still just for
a few minutes
well can you talk about free diving I
mean what's the technical skill involved
here it just seems um
it seems exceptionally difficult like
for most people that swim you go
underwater it's it's hard so what what's
the skill there you know I think
you probably can get good or better at
freediving by training so you have
different techniques uh you can train in
swimming pool and you can say you know
frankly for me
um I go at the bottom of the swimming
pool and I sit there and then you have
relaxation uh techniques some people
meditate I can't I am not a good person
that can meditate or if I do I don't
know about it and but um my way of doing
things and and taking my mind off the
situation I'm in is by singing my head I
I love music or hearing music and in
fact knowing the kind of song I'm
singing I know about the length of time
that I'm staying on the water as well so
this is how you know so this is my own
way people have different ways what kind
of music are we talking about all sorts
of Music can be classical can be pop
music and you know just songs when you
really know that you are relaxed
and something I experience actually at
20 000 feet which was the greatest
experience of my life uh in those in
those terms is when you forget that you
have water around you at that point uh
you cannot tell whether you are the
water or water is you there is actually
no separation anymore and I felt that uh
when I was training in a swimming pool I
never could have imagined that I would
feel that way once on top of that
volcano and it happened and it was
absolutely amazing it was you know we
were talking about how life
Consciousness permeates the universe at
that point in time on that volcano that
day
it took me by surprise I was not
expecting it everything around me the
lake was
Arctic blue with all the ray of the Suns
you can
you could tell them apart every single
one of them I was surrounded by Golden
darts
and it was the most incredible
experience and I don't know if it's that
kind of environment that led me to just
you know go into whatever state of
meditation or whatnot but all of a
sudden
there was no separation anymore between
me the water the volcano and if I came
with questions they didn't matter
anymore because for that fraction of a
second it seemed that I had all the
answers of the in the universe was it
the connectedness with everything you
can call it that way I still don't know
what it means you know literally but it
is that moment where you feel that it
doesn't matter it really doesn't matter
anymore it was a absolutely absolute
peace absolute understanding and it was
incredible it was an absolute uh
awareness could you describe it as
beautiful
that would go beyond that I think that
there is clearly in my mind today no
words that can express how perfect this
was it does that start to speak to why
you love diving or is there something
special about that place
diving at such elevations and volcanoes
you know I started diving pretty much
this is the first thing I did when I was
near water in fact there is a very fun
little incident with my parents me being
on the shore of the lake on vacation I
was
three years old maybe and I had this
little Life Savers you know on my arms
and my parents were not watching and in
my little brain I still can remember
today saying well
nothing bad can happen to me I cannot
drown if I go underwater see that's the
logic of a three-year-old yes yeah it
kind of works I mean that's yeah well
pretty brilliant so I removed
the Lifesavers that I had and I just
went in the water my mom said before she
could do anything I was under and it was
like a natural thing and for me I felt
immediately at home and and and you know
as little as I was completely and it
goes beyond that you know this sense of
connectiveness or Oneness or whatever I
always felt
good and and uh underwater so it doesn't
matter really if it's 20 000 feet that
the thing that's better at that point is
that you need to get there so you need
to get with all the gears with your
hiking tracking equipment High
mountaineering gears and when you get on
top of that you have to remove all that
and don't a suit
is there something uh you can speak to
the challenging aspects of that process
or is it just like this rigorous process
that's well designed you have to go
through and you don't think
this is where most of the risk is
because
you can be well prepared but for one
reason or another you get sick you know
and you can get sick not only because of
high altitude sickness it can be a
number of things or you can be tired or
you can catch a cold and then of course
you have the mountain itself
we had a magnitude 7.8 earthquake
hitting one day when we are 50 meters
away from the summit so you can't
obviously plan for that no you can't and
that's the acts of God you know uh
working with NASA uh although I am the
director of the city Institute I my
grants are coming from NASA so I'm a
NASA contractor and every time we go to
those environments we have to go through
the rigorous process of training with
NASA and checking all the boxes for
safety so they are training and training
and training us and I have to thank them
because a lot of those trainings are the
things that are in your brain when these
kind of things happen you know how to
react and you are not freaking out but
in all of the things they are training
us for you have the green risk the
yellow risk and the red risk so the
green risks are basically the don't be
stupid that don't do the kind of thing
you wouldn't be doing at home like it's
jumping you know on rocks that are not
stable you can tweak your ankle you know
and then you have other risks like high
altitude sickness how you prepare for
that how you recognize that these are
the yellow risks and then the red risk
the red bricks are what they call the
acts of gods the kind of thing that they
can happen you know there is nothing you
can do about it and then you accept that
when you do that so those are
volcanic eruptions when you're in this
kind of environment earthquakes
and everything that an Avalanches for
instance so you're in this Giant
mountain and it's shaking no it's not
shaking that's the interesting think
part of it there was a whole background
of things that happened that day when we
we started off but we got to 50 meters
from the summit and I have part of my
Logistics team that is at the foot of
the mountain and being so close to the
summit we have to go under other hand of
lava so it's just like we are just under
this big Vault of lava and it's actually
beautiful if you want something
beautiful is the ultiplano scene from 20
000 feet it's just absolutely stunning
The Colors the colors are that of early
Earth which means primordial Earth its
occurs yellows oranges browns
with a dark blue sky and so you're just
you know it's a time machine you're just
out there and you're climbing 42 degree
slopes so all of a sudden I'm right next
behind the guide and the guy that's in
with us it's family you know we've been
together for 10 years and he's starting
to do that
I don't discuss when Macario do that you
know I I listen and I ask the team to do
the same thing where maybe half a dozen
and then I want to talk to him and say
what's going on he's on the radio and
then he gives me the radio I'm talking
to my logistic chief officer who was at
the bottom and he said we're having a
tremendous earthquake
uh it was saying that the uh actually
the ground was waiting it was so bad
and it was freaking out because he said
everything is avalanching and I'm very
puzzled because we are in a very
dangerous part of the volcano nothing's
happening I turn around and then this is
when I realized there is just absolutely
everywhere
everything that I saw two minutes before
it's gone just disappear into a wall of
dust but nothing's happening where we
are and uh our our friends down uh they
were freaking out because they were
seeing everything avalanching and
especially the other side of the
mountain we were on was a balancing so
they have no visuals they have no visual
they thought that we are caught in the
Avalanche so I said no but some uh so at
that point so they thought you were
screwed yeah and I said okay so if this
is what's happening then I'm taking
everybody
to the summit because we have a very
large crater that will take care of
avalanching will be safe and I'm waiting
for the Aftershock because this is what
you do uh you know when you have
earthquakes so here we go taking
everybody in the crater and now you have
half a dozen scientists in the crater
with the Cradle Lake and this is why we
came for so we just had a 7.8 earthquake
and what do you think they do well of
course they do the signs they came to to
do so the only thing is that I couldn't
because my radio was only working when I
was on the rim of the crater but I had a
little assistant with me a a young
Bolivian teenager had been shadowing me
for three weeks so I knew exactly what
to do and he said no you don't no
problem give me your back I'll do the
sampling for you so I was monitoring uh
the situation and I'm scared
I wasn't at that point
and
there was another moment my friend
downstairs I could you know at the foot
yeah we've known each other as I said
we're family this team is family we've
known each other I am the gunmather as
kids so we we are close
and I could feel for the first time in
in my life that he actually was scared
and he was calling me every 30 seconds
telling me stuff I said you have to stop
this now
just call me to give me information that
is useful for me to make decisions
and so
um I say okay what's going on all right
it tells me you know there is still
avalanching Etc and then a few minutes
later he calls me to say I think that
last car is erupting so now I have to
tell you we are on a volcano the next
volcano we share a slope with it is a
low a little lower but that's the most
temperamental volcano of the entire
chain and this one as an history of
eruption and then my friend is telling
me that the volcano seems to be starting
to erupt if that volcano goes up we have
nowhere to go
that got my attention
so if you say scared I would say that I
got the realization that what that meant
I went called for like a fraction of a
second but that meant that just my
adrenaline started to kick in and it was
a very very strange experience because
now you have tunnel vision it's about
survival and I say okay now you are
going to tell me what I need to know you
know tell me what do you see say I see
smoke say what kind of smoke is it it's
white I say no big deal that's water
vapor okay where it's going it's going
to Argentina that was the opposite
direction where we are I said okay I'm
staying where I am because right now
there is no you know no danger
and there are still the issue of the
Aftershock
I didn't want to have the team caught in
the Gully in the central Gully of the
volcano with the Netherlands coming Eros
so sit there
and he called me after that and say well
you know it's still going to Argentina
fine okay
um and then a little later he calls me
and say Natalie
um things are changing here say okay
what's going on I say well the cloud is
a little yellow
and I was thinking myself
what does it mean when it's yellow
sulfur and then when you have sulfur
mixed with the water vapor or the water
in your lungs this turns into sulfuric
acid
then you're really screwed and I say
okay
um where thank you for the information
where where is the club going is it the
wing is Shifting it's coming your
direction
so yeah that was a day like that you
know and I am talking to him on the
radio and I'm turning around and as I
turn around I see the clouds starting to
pop on the opposite side of the rim you
know
so at that time we had no choice anymore
because now you have to figure out
what's going to kill you first and so
there was the risk or the potential of
an avalanche
but at least you can see the rocks
the guest is going to kill you before
you can see it yeah so I called
everybody back we got our stuff
um I didn't give too much detail but I
say it's time to go
downhill and fast
so which we did we stopped only when we
were at Mid camp and then at that point
we saw the cloud just completely
covering the summit where we were so we
did well to bail out
but that was 500 meter
500 meter high oven and we were so we
are safe I was just making sure that it
would not go down the slope where we
were we were safe so we stayed and you
know just rested for a little while and
after that we descended and it was all
on adrenaline I can tell you what I had
two on my crew with headaches as part of
one of them was because of the altitude
we climbed very fast the other one was
because of the cloud she was the closest
to the cloud when uh it happened so we
didn't send it fast wow that was close
that was close and it's interesting how
the human body and mind works because I
know that from the moment my friend told
me that the volcano seemed to be
erupting I was going on adrenaline
but when we got close to them and I saw
him we are getting close to the cars I
saw him come in towards me and the slope
all of a sudden all the adrenaline went
away
I was a mess I had to find the first
rock and sit down yeah it was gone I
mean fascinating so you just basically
physically mentally collapsed once you
saw so there was nothing left of me I
got in the car and I felt in the cars we
were heading back towards a camp I could
have passed out I really fought back and
I'm not the kind of passing out really
you know easy but there was nothing left
I had no energy no nothing
it's fabulous how you react and how this
is embedded in your brain from and of
evolution of reaction to a dangerous
situation basically
the drive to survive yeah something like
that